if I've got my theta axis right I'm
gonna do the reciprocal of sine so this
is the cozec theta axis now just like
before when I did tan I noticed all
everywhere the tans denominator is zero
BAM I get massive total right
well the denominator of this also is
zero
frequently okay look at all these spots
here everywhere sine theta passes
through the axis I'll get an asymptote
okay so I have a look at him zero 180
360 right let's draw it in
okay I'm going to label these asymptotes
in a second but I'm in a little bit of a
hurry
okay now let's think about what are the
next easiest parts to draw I have all of
these asymptotes okay
well I'm trying to do reciprocals right
reciprocals so the easiest of numbers to
take the reciprocals off ah all the
points where sine is 1 because the
reciprocal of 1 is 1 right
so here where I've equal to 1 Kosek will
also be equal to 1 so I'm gonna put a
point there
okay
that's where it's one down here I've got
minus 1 what's the reciprocal of minus 1
also minus 1 all right but then what's
happening on the site what's happening
on the sighs well I have a look here in
between 0 and 180 for sewing okay dirt
from 90 degrees which is a non point and
I go forwards side is getting smaller
the denominator is getting smaller we
saw what happened when you got a small
denominator right when you get a smaller
moment I know what happens to the whole
thing it increases you gets really big
right sure it's gonna do this it's gonna
go crazy on the left-hand side when I go
from 90 to the left toward zero it's
three exactly the same thing right this
symmetry up here so there's gonna be
symmetry down here right it's also sky
okay it doesn't take too much thought to
realize gonna do the same thing but
negative down here
sign was periodic for 360 degrees her
stack is also periodic for 360 degrees
the same shape